thank you very much
item number one of tonight's agenda is
rhapsodes one counselor mrs. Mason and
counselor Carlton item number to
substitute members there are none item
number three members attending
[Music]
I think just to iterate I mean it's an
annual report to raise awareness amongst
members around and the council's use of
Ripa if it's only to acknowledge that we
haven't used our powers so this reports
hopefully is self-explanatory in details
that we haven't used our powers this
year but obviously people so many
assurances through the policy that were
prepared should we use them and it does
make some minor recommendations around
authorized officers there's some change
in staff and subsequently authorised
officers are changing so that's the
recommendation from the questions
protoss
okay but I just want some territory
around where there are quite a number of
people nine as an authorized applicant
when it's a possible don't use we do we
need what seems like that if not all AG
large proportion of the Environmental
Health Department as a authorize that
can presumably really angry as you need
that many
if the authorized applicant is to is the
person to applying for the state of the
work I don't just want to get my head
around why there's so many throwing this
ship I don't think there's any reason I
think there has been some comment made
by the independent inspector as an
important and profile number I mean to
take the truth you know the training
that we do and does is food background
investigator eat type training and does
the parish should we need to but I agree
there doesn't need to be that we start
it always has and I should say they've
been on there quite a long time so it's
not as if we City to take them off
training facility there's not an issue
that we would look to people to me looks
like we've got an awful lot of things it
doesn't money it doesn't no no there's
no criticism and there's been no crystal
very kind the inspector actually made
was the appointment of the authorizing
officers they said because we used it
sparingly we had too many or last year
we got or we lost one officer planning
we took off this year with those in
Martin we're not actually replacing
Martin with anybody
we reduced my yeah that's down to three
we've we've gone to the authorized a
princess the people who can actually go
into the magistrates call yes helps the
event dealing with something is better
than the officer involved can go rather
than trying to pass it to someone else
and pass information that it's probably
the question you want to ask as well
yeah but we're never we haven't been
openly criticized it's not sure they
haven't criticized us on that um but
it's also we give the training so those
officers don't actually fall found a
bring her by mistake right so they
understand what referees and don't
actually do something yeah so as they
are trained yeah well not be yeah and
that could ease another yeah
who we're taking Thank You chairman he's
on you on six point two it's pretty I
know it's them Chris and departments be
noted into the gray and brown it just
was great out there
change and now the other thing you
thought it was them
Twitter's actually an open platform so
there's very limited you can Twitter
people thank you so we can thanks a lot
yeah yeah yeah recommends to Council
that the amendments to the council's
River policy set out in section 4
[Applause]
too much the reason we set down in the
mind also originally was I guess a
transparent way of prioritizing the
complaints are coming investigations are
coming so changing categories we have a
now you to see which in many ways when
resources allow time that my
observations of the services that
although there can be minor presence of
planning that almost become labor
disputes you say is that good use of the
source when I guess visible from the
road cycle in terms of planning that but
that we need to be constraining
abilities upon so that was my thinking
behind reviewing that but I guess it's a
it's almost we just needed to
it's going to take action these times
girls can be yeah I mean this our
current targets for undertaking site
visits offset at achieving sixty percent
success rate and at the present moment
category of cases we will say we will
visit within one day and by a large we
achieve that 100% category baby is
currently set up seven days and we're
pretty good
it's the category see places that tend
to have an effect on overall performance
because we have to currently that's
Khattak receive the only other category
that we've got we used to say that we
would visit them within 10 days that was
then extended to 15 and we're now
seeking to extend that even further now
the main purpose about these is that we
have to go through like a triaging
process and because we have got you know
we have got unlimited resources of
resources that we have to work with we
have to direct that result to the more
serious breaches and although we are
sneaking in the noon plan to have
categories city extended to the 30 days
it doesn't mean to say that we're going
to visit every category cinco's believe
in 30 days
those that need to be doesn't eat a lot
quicker and we visit each I placed as
myself as 10 later but I also have a
full caseload so I thought you know I've
got a full officers caseload and I also
am the team leader on the team and then
I have one other officer who is a senior
so you are still quite limited yeah it's
been like that firm it's 2015 so it's
what we work with we still deliver in my
mind you know a very good service we
could do a lot more but it's just the
resource that we have to hand at the
contra sorry about the 1.5 million of
funding yes can you just tell us a bit
more about I'd like to say it says that
and the funding through the next round
yes possibly yeah for additional
resources well how do we we we miss this
year's I mean there was funding
available if every this year with
applications open and that's to put a
submission in to apply for funding to
assist to primarily deal with a non
Fry's development in Greendale corsets
government focus one of the criteria for
your application is that you've got an
enforcement plan in place so obviously
we didn't have a plan in place that we
wasn't able to apply for the funding
with this plan in place the next round
we've got a February on the straight
into us their email address in Los Pinos
and we've just had it reviewed I mean
the online reporting forms been there
for you know a while now but we've
actually because we're looking at ways
of working a bit smarter we look to you
know just incrementally just changing
and improving certain elements of the
way that we work and we had in the last
couple of months looked at we revisited
the online form we've actually played
need for mrs. Clare to counsel they so
now that what the residents can do
making actually upload photographs where
they can do that before and we've asked
and we ask them the question how does
this affect you because what we have
found is that we do get people
complaining about things when they're
just out looking at dog and all right it
might be something that is a planning
breach it does need to be investigated
but you know sometimes it's like all
defecate in your driveway and there's no
drainage penalty and it is something
that we need to deal with but it's not
directly affecting them right at that
very moment so it's it's one way of
triaging you know we want to make sure
use that as a torpedo yeah yes indeed
another thing improvement with the form
that we've made is that when we're
looking at reports of their use of the
property what we tend to do is we'll
take the complaint and then we'll
manually send that diary sheets and
paper form for the resident to make a
record of what activity they're
witnessing over a period of 21 to 28
days and what we've done there with the
online reporting form the asks a
question is this in relation to the use
of the property or the use of the land
if they say yes then they get the option
then to go to a link where they can then
access and then actually input each day
what they're really witnessing they save
it and then at the end twenty one or
twenty out days they can then submit
those goals to us so it's a lot swifter
it works I've tested it it's now live
it's been live about a week and a half
two weeks oh yeah I think it will assist
us the submitting of the photographs is
excellent for us because what we've
found in the past that people
we'll describe something to us over the
phone there obviously want us to respond
very quickly so now that we've got
photographs that can be submitted we can
actually visualize what they're
explaining to us over the telephone and
again use that triology that's why we
want to introduce the category day
because you know some of the things that
get reported to us and may not actually
require us to go out immediately they
may not even be a breach of canon
control but it may be lost
you know to actually filter that and
then decide that but yes we will go out
but we'll go out in resources if I knew
is just saying them you've just reviewed
this online portal where you can yes
that loading which was majority of my
questions because of does it have some
sort of flowchart because sometimes
people will go on thinking you're
enforcement and it might not be I've
done this before when I don't know when
stole name the yen dust that comes on
because that isn't actually your part
that's environmental so I'm just
thinking sometimes at that point where
they're filling in the form it might be
that you know you decide for which area
it should be close to it doesn't
currently but that's certainly something
that we can repair and then we now got
you know data digital officer in our IT
department and make the main thing
that's to perform is a possibility we
can certainly look at some sort of
flowchart that enables people to make
sure that they're actually submitting
the right on the right form certainly
willing to have a look
don't you think that any sort of FAQ yes
yes
and then some sometimes it you saying
and I fully appreciate this because like
I told you there's nothing to of them
it's sometimes takes 15 days to see
something hmm does this class in a bit
of a tricky situation if somebody has
reported footings going in day one
mm-hmm when you turn up you've got a
barn bill mm-hmm well I mean obviously
we're safe 15 days but we are triology
meaning just by the nature of the
complaint so if for example somebody's
reporting that this routine is going in
and it's in Greenville then obviously
that wouldn't be a category study that
would be a B and would be out there
within seven days if not earlier
sometimes you know we would go out the
next day depending on the bridge
depending what people are telling us if
it's in a residential area and it's an
extension to a dwelling house okay it
may not be permitted development but
they may if there was to submit
retrospective man your permission
actually get consent so does it warren
and enforcement officer to get out there
immediately the neighbor may wish us to
but we have to go through that thought
process of well okay this may not be
permitted development but you know if
it's half a meter over committed
development is likely to get consent
they make you know and then we would
obviously responding to them
because I just our Chairman service
cost-wise if somebody applies a plan
planning permission
what's the cheaper option then they
apply the Planning Commission or is
retrospectives the same price cheaper
more expensive it's so price if they if
they don't have a commission and
retrospectively and we can see the the
type of development it's unlikely to get
consent that's obviously in our own view
person with you as professional officers
then we would potentially decide what
I'm not we're going to take enforcement
action they can then apply for planning
permission through the enforcement of
field process but that's doubly the face
okay
very quickly we talked about there the
improvements of the web portal is this
now the preferred contacts point for
residents or there's no and what I mean
we we will take complaints over the
phone
years ago we use does that have to be in
writing but I mean we've moved off
specifically now we will take complaints
on the phone or take a an email
directing to a generic email address
somebody could potentially come into
reception report it but you know the
ease of the online forum is that you
know people can uses its we do get a
majority or
and complaints coming now boy I be by
your my phone
brilliant face not expected yeah another
brilliant thank you
second one was a follow-up to the
application for funds we're hoping to
submit a new one should have come up in
February and was the the lack of a plan
the the only kind of stumbling block for
this one so that we have other
challenges no I think if we did had a
plan in place we would have certainly
looked at submitting their a bit
brilliant thank you and then a final one
around the the performance primarily
being it's a result of the Caspari see
and is this around the volume of the
category see do we get a lot of them or
is it I've actually got this month okay
so just to give you a snapshot we've had
19 new cases in during the month of
September 12 of those work has at least
a six where they own one was inside
Thank You chef you said about getting
the funding on your plan Kevin thanks
pepper do you have to do that or do you
have something else to do it for you
what submit the application it will be
us that primarily what silly and the
reason no no thanks question having the
resources to actually do that if you're
just still doing important work just now
yeah I've got some February yeah it's
it's still a very very tight window yeah
I don't have only it takes to do the
application well and the idea would be
is that obviously they've published
those authorities that have been
successful in applying for funding my
first point of contact would be to
contact on the most authorities and look
to see what their funding bit look like
and do something along the same lines
really I mean the idea of the funding is
to look at addressing unauthorized
development in the Greenville you know I
mean we've got we've got a number of
cases that we need to do so compliance
work we've already taken formal action
we make it a priority to do the funding
of the good it is an interest to us
we've got an expensive Greenville Police
have many issues I think it's relevant
to us to coquí's funding remiss of us as
a council not protection go for it and
what biggest concern office is the
resource issue if we've got on to our
officers in the department are working
flat-out to actually then put aside some
time to do this the challenges of
managing local government resources
really I mean it is across the board but
I mean certainly I'm not be involved as
well
so you know aspects with on to between
us I'm sure we will get that together so
if you get someone to do and justify the
cost of getting that person to do if you
get funded odds against but I think it's
not to our economy I think I'm sure
would be together thank you thank you
and just a couple questions around the
forum on 7.24 which is the assessable
way to school more than fire free
questions I suppose one easiest possible
to get that from you
was it all complicated one is is it a
fairly standard form which most
authorities would use the second
question is on another six I don't
understand I don't quite understand what
that's within six months of immunity
means my scores two and less than three
balance schools one I think yeah I'm not
sure whether the school should fly so
just a bit of clarity around there and
on number five the the relevance of the
complainant and some we are as cows as
quite often asked to complain on behalf
of risk they may not feel comfortable
playing England but again it looks like
it goes back to my nose where it's
better they complain this themselves
rather than we can play for them I don't
want to know why we as counselors are
considered lesson not going to put this
a staff member would score more points
than a complaint but they passed on by
council I want to know the rationale
behind that okay yeah thank you very
much for those questions and okay so
this this harm assessment form has been
in place and we've used this since about
2010 it was approved by members at a
time and and it's a scheme that was
adopted by ruptured District Council
that Huntington had actually been using
we went to an enforcement officers for
and
and it was a presentation and form that
presentation and number of authorities
adopted the scheme so its origin is
Huntingdon but I think this is an a
direct copy of Huntington's game it's
very similar but when it went through
members for approval the there were some
adjustments to the weighting of the
actual scores because on the second
question the age of the breech so the
alignment of this is probably a bit
confusing so less within six months so
it's less than six months or within six
months of immunity so sure members aware
that planning breaches become lawful
after a period of time so if its
operational development that's within
four years so four years or more the
actual breach will become lawful so if
we've got a building that's been up and
complete substantially complete for
three years and six months then
obviously that's within six months of it
becoming immune from the enforcement
action so therefore it'd be given higher
score yeah and then obviously if the
breach is less than three months old
it's quite a new breach so therefore
that scores one it's you know it's I
suppose its impact is fairly known it's
causing concern to residents so
therefore it warrants a score because
it's a new form of development or a new
use that's been occurring that started
to occur within three months if he's
long three months old then it's been
there we've only just received the
complaint so one has to ask then you
know the harm that's being caused so
it's not you know a perfect system it's
to enable us to triage that's fine I
just need to understand what the first
one maybe I understand correctly
alright this mine and then the way that
the scoring stand for the actual source
of the complaints well an immediate
neighbor would obviously be that person
that's affected by presumably the most
and a staff member would actually have
made seen the bridge made an assessment
there and then and actually you know
that would they would be bringing it to
our attention because they know that
it's an actual breach that needs to be
deal so the reference to staff is a
member of the planning department what
explains that perfect counsel did you
say and were they successful in I don't
know yeah I mean this is this scheming
was 2010 I think they doctored it two
years prior to that I mean keep the home
assessment form isn't isn't necessarily
part of the new enforcement plan we've
been using this harm assessment scheme
for nine years that's how we close small
proportion of our cases you know the the
transgressor gets a letter to say that
you do need planning permission however
we've made an assessment that permission
is likely to be granted so we put the
ball firmly back in the trans dress
oppressors cool yeah cool
and then basically it's up to them
whether or not they apply for planning
permission or not but we do put a caveat
on the letter that basically says if you
don't apply for planning permission it
might affect the sale of your property
further down the line because any
purchases solicitors going to be asking
the question did day extension get
planning
so just that last census only place it's
made aware of that yes
I cannot say if they fill in the form in
online that's probably on now I'm
shooting it says on the online form
about your details will be kept
confidential yeah I would meet somebody
fun yeah we all right I mean if I had a
pound for every time a complainant said
to me will you keep my details
confidential I mean it's a standard
question that they are somewhere on ways
say to them I'm focusing more on the
better it might be given that's why we
would always ask their consent first
what what tends to happen is is that we
get complaints made obviously we say to
them the details are kept confidential
and then when we end up at a public
inquiry we invariably want them to give
evidence at the public inquiry so we
have to go back to the complainant and
say will you give evidence and they
don't want to which obviously weakens
our case I think that and then similarly
if we end up in court we ask them will
are you prepared to give a witness
statement so they're always we always go
back to them and ask their consent so
they're detailed or section 10 meters
what happens if down basis maybe you
want me the last few points
yeah should there not be hot or an
addition to that which well is there a
way that if you happy with the way which
is happy there so but if someone was
looking at that yeah I was referring to
that because it complained
oh we came I mean it is just basically
we can just refer it to the complaints
procedure and it will be dealt with as
an official complaint but yeah we can
certainly out there in it it seemed
dropped I mean there are a couple of
typos still in here that need to be any
minor ones
I just wanted to refer that to the six
point one point and this is point one
that you just mentioned so it says there
and the only time Confederate Statehouse
may have to be disclosed would be
ordered to do so by judging a court of
law
but then you said that you asked their
permission yeah at any point
are they they enforced to give a
statement or to have their details I
mean if they don't want to I mean it's a
planning breach at the end of the day
they're not compelled to okay it's just
the wording would sort of imply that
they could be forced to and would that
put people off of making of campaign if
Gerald
yeah I mean we're not dealing with we're
dealing with planning brie cheese yeah
yeah I just wonder would it put someone
offers better all at some point I may be
yeah it's just purely yet word will
soften that guess it's a follow-up to to
the same point is there a sense of
circumstances that may mean that someone
refuses to comply any further with an
investigation ie not give a witness
statement for their original complaint
is then put forward to the court of law
and if so guesses maybe the the point
counselor is referring to at that point
even though they haven't given consent
and then thought at the time that they
made the complaint or that identity
really protected
it could then be revealed because their
original okay what we would do is we
would submit the complaint details but
we would read out the information
if you fall just a month Ruthie
okay so the first one on there 7:19 the
planning enforcement plan and that would
be coming off because council your
recommendation it won't be a key
decision anymore okay the people in
community is important plan
ten nine teams on their previously as
well as the energy strategy 1219 the
young new one number thirteen nineteen
the brownfield Glen Register 2020 and to
be published in January 2020 s an annual
one
[Music]
[Applause]
next month I'm afraid we're gonna suffer
Marcos once more graphically management
of open spaces in new developments
that's coming next month neutral yes
that's the one Whitter no cancer sparing
has mentioned for nothing I spoke about
it as well so this is rather than this
is about now policy because obviously we
don't cut grass on new development and
this we put a contract for it so this is
going to be about a policy in relation
to what we could do about it
or is this about have we got any
contracts they're doing it could be
either way the way it's written
yeah from previous it was about the old
developments where the companies would
stop doing it and we'd ended up over as
majors move and then we've got the new
ones and looking to make sure they come
back but if anything you want him to
cover in that report as we have never
seen time to ask people to make sure
because I did do that if this is wrong
lines of the management so we'll include
possibilities of either owning shares in
the major companies having the
directorship or of the management
managing companies or have actually
taken over for the matron companies are
they all three irrelevant to some extent
topic I think we decide we have a say as
a at least a site and now things done as
we all remember we all come from the
back foot sometimes when these must know
main lanes Mary's come up
who's gonna management well the
company's gone bust now imagine and
something's quite old there'll be a we
do need to make what is our policy to
counsel in these situations up do we
take them or don't you take them on
invocation I've approached because green
k we have successfully taken on the
action than one haven't they actually do
these to itself no the one off brains
like they know how to contract or
contract you buy that that's great that
company are they which is a slightly
different there is a management company
exactly so there's all this is what
there's also a vacuum and when there is
the men who can't get our ceases to
exist
yes what happens in a situation I think
you know fortunately opportunites always
been kind of small packages that you've
just gone up just but there's gonna be a
treasure at some father actually was
like gosh she's quite a big area to take
home you know it would I think the North
changed on this where the development
company would sell the management
company and then they could put a
pedestrian and economical crisis I think
that that it's been taken away from them
so it's going to keep reasonably static
so I don't think so many people of these
companies are going to dive in to buy
them off of the development
these which gives us the opportunity to
surely this was the very point that I
was when I was working with Marcus we
were trying to be better but then we ran
into other issues of tech or one all the
rest of it it is a his master said by
default nine times out of ten we end up
doing it okay we we've now got all the
properties there are - there council tax
or whatever so and to try and tell you -
some of them well I'm sorry but you've
got a special agreement it doesn't cut
much but there is the opportunity and we
have this great white cream yeah where
the developer was very keen to work with
the District Council from day one I
don't know I obviously I came out of it
then but have whether that was developed
but we did run into other issues not
racists on a number of occasions where
we raised this problem with tackle and
all the rest of it and I'm not quite
sure how we can now how then how we now
stand so you might want to elaborate on
that as well except the UM how income
limits a thing but no same tickle we
kind of about you text on it yeah that's
what people yes I mean I think we need
to be told
yeah what what the problem is and is
there any way around it is your problem
even in reality yeah because we will we
will look into work we I don't know what
the situation is marketers now with
better than Council with regard to the
trees that's different I know it's
slightly different but it was an
opportunity to develop our ask your base
and revenue stream so then a grass
cutting yet plenty of opportunities all
these new developments going on they're
all gonna need service in Ramah having
linden outside sources in yeah
I know I suppose the only other thing is
some working groups yeah - Dominic
Danielle to join that if that's okay she
showed interest already yeah